this morning we continued our promise to
feature at least one new book a week
during the pandemic today an exclusive
about the biggest search in the history
of the FBI and the capture of the most
wanted man in America our focus to
authors and a former agent who changed
the course of history the target James
Whitey Bulger the infamous Bob Boston
mobster whose much-discussed story was
largely incomplete until now what you're
about to see release for the first time
are the last known photos of Whitey
Bulger along with a more accurate story
of what happened while he was on the run
and after he was caught plus one final
remaining mystery the last known photo
of Whitey Bulger alive is hardly in
fitting with his menacing persona
it's him in prison with his Native
American art teacher another with the
inmates he befriended miles away from
decades of murder mayhem and the most
exhaustive manhunt in FBI history the
full story now told in the new book
hunting whitey by dave wedge and Casey
Sherman as a writer you know Dave and I
have read everything that has been
written about Whitey Bulger and his life
of crime but what about the 16 years
that he was a fugitive that story has
not been told what was his life like
behind bars the hero of this story is a
former agent who was running the case
when Bulger was captured marine Gleeson
hasn't spoken on-camera about any of it
since she left the bureau seven years
ago when you opened the book for the
first time your name is the first two
words in the book your reaction I had to
close it why did you close it there were
so many people involved in this case and
it just made me a little uncomfortable
that's all I eventually picked it back
up a couple days later and started
reading it and thought this is pretty
good
James whitey Bulger's life of crime that
began in the 1950s eventually put him in
charge of Boston's Winter Hill Gang
for decades he infamously manipulated
FBI agent John Connolly trading
information and misinformation
Bulger's been portrayed loosely by Jack
Nicholson in 2006's The Departed
and directly by Johnny Depp in 2015's
black mass get the FBI to fight he was
about to be indicted and sent away when
he slipped away on Christmas Eve 1994
and remained a fugitive for more than 16
years how did he stay on the run for
that long that was the thing that drove
me crazy when I got to Boston people
thought that we did not want to catch
him because we were afraid of what he
might say if we did catch them and there
couldn't be anything further from the
truth the thing that really disturbed me
the most was he was like a myth it was
almost had like a John Gotti like Robin
Hood type rapport with the neighborhood
and Southie that he grew up in and that
just was never an OK thing for me I knew
people who knew him who talked about him
and and there is that reverence for many
of them still yeah I don't it didn't
work well I'm like this guy is you know
a stone-cold killer Noreen Gleason
helped solve the case by changing the
game focused not on Bulger but his
girlfriend Catherine Greig we really
never took a look at Catherine I think a
lot of people thought that lady had
killed her and I was like yeah I don't
know I don't think so he needs women in
his life he was very dependent on women
the FBI is trying something new to track
down one of its most wanted suspects is
an announcement it's hope someone will
recognize the longtime girlfriend a
fugitive Boston mob boss James Whitey
Bulger who's been the book is called
hunting whitey right I hunt and fish up
here all the time but if I went hunting
and I kept hunting every day for years
doing the same thing but never was able
to catch my prey
why would I continue to do it that way
so this was a great opportunity it's
just kind of flip the switch a little
bit you weren't hunting whitey then you
were hunting Catherine if you know how
to hunt you can always find what you're
after if he just changed the strategy
she recognized that for so long the FBI
and other law enforcement agencies were
hunting an elderly white man in
sunglasses and a Red Sox hat now I can
walk down the street in Boston and spot
five of those guys right away and Noreen
Gleason said were focused too much on
him let's focus on his girlfriend and
that broke the case wide open we had
captured one of the FBI's ten most
wanted fugitives the ads that Gleason
put together led to a tip from a woman
from Iceland of all places who once knew
Greg is the woman who fed stray cats
when a tipster Greg and Bolger all lived
in the same Santa Monica California
neighborhood at approximately 5:45 p.m.
Pacific Standard time using a ruse
agents and other task force members
lured mr. Bulger out of his apartment I
think that he hid in plain sight
he really was a very disciplined person
he covered his tracks very well he knew
evasion techniques so I think that he
did a pretty good job but at the end we
were better after Bulger was sent to
prison the first attempt on his life was
made in less than a month he was stabbed
in the head and almost died during
recovery he formed a friendship with an
art teacher Clement chip Janis wedge and
Sherman reveal the dozens of letters the
two exchanged and the bond they shared
this photo is I mean it's interesting to
look at it's right it's not what you'd
expect to see of the last known photo of
what evolves you know every every
surveillance photo of Bulger he's
scowling and it's shot from a distance
here's Bulger behind prison walls
smiling and it shows that the pressure
was kind of off at that time he didn't
have to look over his shoulder anymore
to get captured he did to protect his
life and he would tell this fellow
prisoner when I get it I hope they give
it to me quick because I gave it quick
Bulger was eventually murdered in prison
with a padlock and sock less than 12
hours after mysteriously being
transferred to a West Virginia facility
in 2018 the main suspect is a former
mobster who answered to La Cosa Nostra
why was whitey killed in prison
one is that he's a notorious rat he's
one of the biggest most infamous rats
ever in the history of organized crime
he put a lot of people in jail his
actions put a lot of people in the
morgue
specifically Italian mobsters Italian
mobsters don't forget stuff like that no
one has officially been charged in that
case but that open crime is far from the
largest open question
when Bulger was captured he was found
with a cache of weapons and $800,000
hidden behind his apartments walls
Bulger however spent decades stuffing
away millions more in safety deposit
boxes all over the country do you think
we'll ever find out where all that money
is I think that people at know Bulger
know where the money is and the FBI
agents that we interviewed for the book
said follow some of those people around
because eventually they're going to lead
you to the lottery if there's millions
of dollars still missing where is it and
do you think it ever is found if those
are assets that can still be seized
somehow and people are continuously
working on this then they'll come up
with it you think it'll happen people
thought that we would never get him so
I'm always very optimistic when it comes
to that today as the search for the
missing millions continues Bulger is
buried in a cemetery in West Roxbury
Massachusetts
Whitey's name is not on the grave when
people think about Whitey Bulger today
what should they think good riddance
Dana Katherine Craig whitey Bulger's
girlfriend is now out of prison she is
living in the Boston area why is it
important to find all that money if it's
out there well that money would go to
victims and victims families those who
were affected by whitey Bulger's crimes
I cannot wait to read that book that is
fascinating absolutely fascinating was
already interested yeah great great job
Jeff